The plus 1 in Kruchtens' 4 plus 1 is the use case view.
Use cases are important execution sequences from the external actors or
user's point of view.
We'll have a look at the use case diagram that UML offers.
Some other UML diagrams that can be used to convey individual use cases.
And we'll even see some structured text that can convey a use case.
Here's a use case diagram from UML.
Each of the ovals corresponds to a use case.
The stick figures correspond to external actors.
Some of the lines indicate are, are labeled and
indicate that the particular use case is used for a special purpose such
as being included in another use case or being shared among several use cases.
Important thing is that the use case diagram in UML conveys a set of use cases,
not an individual use case.